let's dive into like tick tock's growth
are you guys hijacked on Trends how
important are keywords or like hashtags
how important is using the music where
do you guys stand on that how important
is the time of day when you post what um
analytics are you guys paying attention
to Beyond just the followers growth what
numbers mean the most to you on a
regular basis how long did it take you
to hit a million on Tick Tock so my most
viewed video was at 24 million I think a
lot of people see Tick Tock it's okay I
get a lot of views but there's no
monetization plan like YouTube will pay
you Tick Tock doesn't how do you start
the monetize and turn into a business I
upload one video a day every single day
for two years yeah how important is it
having a good cover image and how much
time you guys spend on those try
everything host everything and see what
works I did give up at the beginning but
I gave up on the thing that wasn't
working do you guys ever repost a winner
like if it took off and then kind of
stopped a month later or three months
later would you repost the same thing if
that's not working for you like what do
you find is the thing that's working the
best for you right now as we're
recording this I have some to-do's after
this that go and update my tick tock
all right believe Nation we have a
special treat for you today we're going
to talk about how to grow a Tick-Tock
following how to get a million followers
on Tick Tock I am not there yet I've got
600 000 something so I'm still learning
I'm still growing and we have a special
guest with us today Peter prankster in
the house who's going to share some
advice we're gonna pick his brain and
see who we can learn Peter welcome
aboard man thank you so much thanks for
having me I've got my co-host here Ida
who has been uh researching people and
reaching out so Ida invited Peter on so
I had to why why did you love Peter why
did you invite him on and just give us
your little take care so the reason I
reached out to Peter is because I looked
at what he does online and in this day
and age where a lot of kids are out
there just doing whatever thing on
social media I saw Peter and his friends
there taking the time to make people
have a nice day so I saw you and your
friend you called on the boy band and
you guys were singing some songs to
random people it's just like you just
want to have them to have an
entertaining day and so it was really
interesting for me to see that you're
using your craft to be able to impact
people in a positive way
and you're growing and following with it
thank you so much I really enjoy doing
it I love it so we're going to dive into
Peter's hacks and ideas and suggestions
and he can teach me a few things but I'm
curious why did you get started man like
what's the origin story of you getting
started on Tick Tock I've always been
kind of an Entertainer I was like the
class clown that wanted to do
impersonations to my friends of you know
different cartoon characters whatever
and I just decided to take it to social
media not really knowing what was going
to happen would have never expected to
get over a million followers that's uh
an afterthought but I just wanted to
entertain people so I grabbed a few
friends I ended up doing this whole
puppet thing which was totally
unexpected and just it just kind of
morphed from one thing to another into
what it has become
and are you loving tick [ __ ] just so
much more than YouTube shorts or
Instagram or other platforms I guess you
could say it tick tock is the platform
that I have my biggest following on so
that makes that special to me but I do
work with other platforms such as
YouTube and have been able to grow a
little bit of following on there as well
I forget how long it took me to hit a
million on YouTube
like eight years nine years something
crazy how long did it take you to hit a
million on Tick Tock I think it was
close to two years okay
okay and and what kind of cadence were
you were you putting out content on I
upload one video a day every single day
for two years yeah and so how do you go
through at the beginning when it's not
doing what you think it's gonna do or
you just start getting traction right
away so I had already been posting to
YouTube I used to do like prank videos
public uh social experiments so whenever
I went into Tick Tock I already had a
significant amount of content from
YouTube so my first videos were just
reformatting YouTube videos into shorter
tick tocks so that was an easy start and
I started gaining traction within like
two days of starting Tick Tock I had 25
000 followers in like the first week or
something and I'm texting my friends
saying I'm just now on Tick Tock is this
normal rate of growth and they're all
saying no
so I I just I was lucky enough that I
had already been going on YouTube so I
just reformatted that and that's how I
had an easy start instead of starting
completely from scratch but now you're
doing dedicated tick tocks yes now I'm
more doing tick tocks for tick tock and
YouTube is an afterthought so it kind of
swapped from what I originally was doing
I love it dude and so for for the people
who are struggling you know your friends
who are like you hit 25k in two days
what
what advice do you give them how do we
start to grow Tick Tock what have you
seen
it's going to be different for everybody
that wants to do content but I think one
of the things that's helped me is I do
family friendly so it's something that
can be watched by all ages you know if
you're familiar with Walt Disney his his
dream was I want to make a theme park
where anybody can go and have fun with
the whole family so that's kind of my
motto of
no language none of this like crazy
stuff I'm just trying to keep it to
where everybody can watch it and enjoy
it so that's one of the things that I
think helped me and just being original
doing things that people haven't
necessarily seen before so I'm doing
that more now with my puppets having
conversations with people that are
surprising is something that really
hasn't been explored too much it's a
very kind of Niche category so I think
those are a couple of things that really
helped me take off I mean I love Disney
is one of my he's one of my heroes and
he wanted to build the parks for his
daughter like he imagined him and his
daughters going and that's why he built
the park so it's a great like imagine if
Disney
had tick tock
they do well like Walt Disney like the
guy like not right not not with Disney
like Corporation Disney now yeah but
Walt Disney to get started
he didn't even have people who like to
make Snow White the first feature-length
movie yeah there weren't enough
animators to do it his style so he he
created an animation school that he took
people through just so that they can
create the the animation for Snow White
um just imagine him or imagine like Jim
Henson
had tick [ __ ] what would he be doing
like he'd be doing this all the Muppets
would be on tick tock
for sure that's kind of what I'm doing
build my own brand of original
characters I mean you've taken it
seriously and and turn it into a
business which a lot of people really
struggle with right like even coming on
you got the merch you got your hat you
got the you got the hoodie on like
you're turning it into something a lot
more than I'm just gonna make some
videos and try to make people laugh so
how do you how do you think through the
business side of I think a lot of people
see Tick Tock it's okay I can get a lot
of views but there's no monetization
plan like YouTube will pay you Tick Tock
doesn't how do you how do you start the
monetize and turn into a business
so what I do the kind of the way I look
at it is get as much as you can out
there I would collaborate with a lot of
different creators I've been reaching
out to celebrities to do videos with
them so I'm trying to get myself out
there in that aspect and as well as
posting often I'm just trying to get
um everything out there that I can
and by posting to more than just Tick
Tock like right now I'm on Tick Tock
Instagram Pinterest
um YouTube
Facebook I I post to different platforms
so I'm trying to gain a following gain
money through more than one platform I'm
just
as many places as I can get my stuff out
there so if I'm not making a lot from
YouTube or Tick Tock maybe combining
those it'll start to be something
significant well we've got uh Michelle
in the house as well and Michelle's got
over a million on Tick Tock as well uh
Ida why don't you uh tell us why
Michelle is here and what you love about
her story too hey Michelle welcome so
the reason I reached out to Nichelle is
because Michelle creates videos which
are all about keeping people safe both
online and offline and a couple of
videos actually stood out to me very
much there's one about the duct tape and
the rubber band and the hotel door you
shouldn't be able to be safe the
break-in at the hotel and then the other
one that really really caught my
attention was the one about the hand
gesture which is this so that saved a
lot of people especially in the in the
pandemic phase in the wrong way in the
thing so those are the two reasons for
which I reached out to Michelle and so
we wanna
I'm pleased to have you here yeah thanks
for having me now do you guys know each
other or know of each other
no all right there you go Michelle meet
Peter prankster and and back and forth
um it's amazing like one of the things I
love doing on the on my YouTube climb up
was meeting other creators and learning
from them and like comparing notes and
seeing what they're up to because once
you get to a certain level there aren't
as many people to to talk to and share
notes and discuss so maybe this creates
a good connection for you guys as well I
have to say you look like a young
version of uh p leader Mark Wahlberg
like from from here anyway you're
looking I'm like oh my God you're like
Mark Wahlberg so funny not the first
time I've heard that thing oh really
okay good good good well what what if
people said you look like Michelle oh my
gosh okay I don't know her name offhand
Stifler's mom
okay where's his mom okay what's her
name I don't know
oh I get it I've got it like three times
so now I'm like okay hang on uh I can't
think of her name right now but it's
funny I used to get Nicholas Cage a lot
when I had more hair that was the one
okay okay
I don't know I don't see it you're like
I don't know I'll take it so we're just
like you actually you remind me of um
iJustine the YouTuber
oh I don't know okay I'll have to I'll
have to Google her
there you go well somebody mentioned I
look like the pitan jungle
um so we were just going through Peter's
kind of origin story while he started on
Tick Tock and then some advice that he
had how about you Nisha like what's what
sparked you getting in on Tech talk uh
well I figured if I was on every other
platform so I figured why not start Tick
Tock because I thought
um well originally I wasn't on Tick Tock
at all because I thought it was for the
younger generation and I'm 48 so it was
just you know and I'm good for 48. Holy
oh well thank you and I just I a little
bit of my story and I won't take up like
forever but it's kind of how it all
happened
um I was a police officer for 15 years
and I actually didn't use much of social
media because back in the day we weren't
really allowed to in fact you know we
weren't allowed to wear makeup not
allowed to wear you know nail polish all
that stuff only because I mean it just
kept it simple
and social media was a very kind of a
No-No you know back in the day so I
don't actually have a lot of pictures or
in that matter of videos of work
um but what what I did used to do kind
of parallel to that was do a lot of
Fitness training so I used to be a
amateur boxer kickboxer and when I
started having children I have four boys
when I started having children I stopped
boxing and I turned to Fitness
competitions so I think you guys know
bodybuilding competitions and all that I
don't do the bodybuilding but I do kind
of like a lower level and so when I
started doing
um Fitness competitions I did that
because I could do uh training for that
on my own time whereas boxing was just
so taxing it was like I had to be at the
gym for you know a couple hours a night
and at a certain time Spar without you
know so Fitness competitions for me were
really easy
so how I ended up getting into social
media is because when you do Fitness
competitions a lot of the girls the guys
do photo shoots afterwards or they just
start getting out a little bit more in
terms of media and so I took to my
social media platforms at the time which
was Facebook and Instagram
um posting you know about Fitness and
then I started I kind of organically
grew this way because the fitness
community and the policing Community is
quite small in the grand scheme of
things and cops are very very particular
who not only they trust but who they you
know I mean get their advice from so
my I I basically started I became a
coach without even realizing it like one
girl came up to me and said hey can you
coach me and I said well I can you know
I could try and my first client she was
my guinea pig and she lost 80 pounds and
so I started to you know whoa who know
who you know coached you and oh Michelle
did so everyone started coming to see me
this and that and over the years I'm
talking like 10 15 years I built a whole
plethora of people
and my policing career was kind of side
by side with my Fitness career and as as
I got more into policing I realized I I
didn't realize I felt that I wasn't
changing the world like I hope to be
when I first joined policing because I
joined because I I genuinely loved the
job and it saved me when I was younger
um I come from a very kind of bad
background the police were there to save
me so I wanted to pay it forward and
give back but I didn't feel that way I
would arrest people put them in jail
they'd come back out like you know it's
and I get it it's it's the system
was Fitness it was different I changed
someone physically it's a whole lot more
than that it's mentally emotionally
they're going through so much so my
passion turned into fitness and I left
policing
to open up a gym which is kind of behind
me like and then my husband same thing
he was he was kind of parallel to me but
he was doing photography so it's kind of
like I was doing the shows and you know
the photography and the fitness the
pictures and so were my colleagues and
we were all in this together
um so I started my social media most
people knew me from Fitness because they
didn't know you know I wasn't allowed to
post police stuff I wasn't yet into the
Tactical safety world but I was I was
just a cop and I wasn't allowed to do
this stuff
and when covet happened I promise I'm
getting to the story uh when covet
happened to shut down my gym and when I
shut down the gym too many times we just
couldn't recover financially and so we
were going to go back to policing but
because that's all I knew and that was
my passion
um we instead turned our gym into a
tactical source so what that means is
all police or Emergency Services
Personnel no more no matter who you are
you come into our store you can buy your
uniform everything except firearms
because I live in Canada
um you can buy everything here so I'm
seeing my old colleagues I have this
thing and and so now my
it's not like my not my passion
necessarily changed I'm still into
helping people but I wanted my social
media to now reflect my new life and I
wasn't sure how to do that and so I
started to continue to post Fitness
stuff
and I said now I'm going to try Tick
Tock because it was covid and I started
posting Fitness stuff and I don't know
people like I don't know if it's because
they're a dime a dozen or there's just
so many people doing Fitness that they
weren't hardly any views and I was
getting frustrated because I was trying
to work so hard to get Tick Tock videos
out there and I'm like no one's watching
this is frustrating
and then
I had an idea I'm like well what if I
use my experience as a police officer
now that it's a little bit more known
and you know you see more cops on on
videos and stuff for you know good and
bad reasons but I said let me try use my
experience as a fighter as like a
Kickboxer unboxer for self-defense stuff
or just how to protect yourself how to
carry yourself your mindset
and my tips on how to keep people safe
from a female officer perspective and in
the background they're kind of throwing
oh hey I owned a tactical shop if you
need any of the items I may have them at
my store but without pushing it too much
without me sounding too much like a
Salesman and this is literally when I
started changing my content to I guess
you can say a specific Niche one video
blew up and I was like whoa you know and
this is I just literally listened to my
audience and I'll still throw in the
fitness video now and again but it's
more based on you know it's not like oh
here do this workout it's like you know
change your mindset you know because
being strong mentally means also
physically so I kind of incorporate it
where you you you're ready you're ready
even set for anything so that's kind of
how I combine them you know I just
listen to my audience now so so Peter
was telling the story and he got 25 000
followers in like two weeks from taking
his videos from YouTube and clipping
them and putting the tick tock sounds
like you had a long journey to like
start getting your Tick Tock off the
ground so how long were you doing
Fitness stuff to then like that video
then blows up
well I I posted like I can't even
remember when I posted my first video on
Tick Tock because it bombed and it was
so much work I kind of took a good break
like I took like an eight-month break I
was like screw this and then when I
posted one video
a couple like like I
said this will happen when kovid shut us
down I was trying to do like my fitness
stuff online and so with that I was
trying to post videos online thinking
you know I don't know what I was
thinking you know they'd blow up but I'm
telling you when I started okay I would
say
2020 so last year
I think it was around mid last year
until December so it took about maybe
six okay let's say eight eight months
and I went my kids were laughing so like
Mom you have like 40 followers and I
ended up I think at one million Before
Christmas last year so it was like it
was literally it took me seven months to
get up to over a million I'm at 1.1 and
a little bit right now but I stalled now
it's like I've just like I'm I go and I
come back you know what I mean so that
first seven eight months just flew it's
been an amazing ride and now it's like
but where are you guys all going like I
don't understand and it feels that
sometimes I now I'm panicking so I'm
like do they not like my content anymore
am I running out of content how can I
create new ideas you know so it's
you know got it okay so Peter she
stalled at 1.1 you're at 1.7 what's
what's the secret to go for 1.1 to 1.7
I'm stalling right now too so you just
never know
we got to do a collaboration maybe maybe
your people will come follow me and my
you know vice versa
how old are you Peter
22. so he's 22. I'm 42. Michelle what
did you say you're 48 I don't believe
that I wanted lie detector test maybe
it's the lighting thank you
Peter what do you think about these all
these Boomers getting into Tick Tock now
I mean you do what you want to do
whatever makes you happy whatever gets
you a living a following you do you
you're here for it yeah I think a lot of
I think at the beginning a lot of people
in my circle is like I mean it's stupid
you're dancing you're doing these little
videos like what's the point how you how
does this become a business how do you
turn this into something and it's really
become
um something giant you know like think
about how how quickly you grew I think a
lot of people are still stuck into
frustration I've only tried it for three
weeks and like it didn't it didn't it
bombed so I'm going to give up guys it
took me five years to get like 10 000
subscribers on YouTube like it took a
long time something like that and it's
like if you don't have it in three weeks
and like I'm a failure and I'm gonna
give up on the platform and kudos to you
Michelle for sticking with it because a
lot of people that's it so
when you're talking to people and they
have that mindset I mean both of you uh
they're starting on Tick Tock they gave
it a they gave it a shot for three weeks
you know I was like I guess I suck this
this doesn't work Peter Nichelle gave me
this advice
what what do you tell them to do it kind
of like what I did is that maybe you
know maybe you're just posting about the
wrong thing or not necessarily wrong
because you could be passionate about so
many things but maybe you're not
listening to what people want to hear
like for me personally I found
in my opinion there wasn't a lot of
women doing what I do so okay okay so
that's good that's a good thing and
maybe that's why you know
um you know and just keep trying to
engage people and try to put out
material that's shareable and you know
sometimes my my stuff is a little bit
tricky because I'll post something and
actually you had a good point like the
one with the duct tape opening oh now
you're showing all the bad people how to
I got so much hate but I was like thanks
for the engagement I didn't say that I
didn't say that wait what did you show
people how to do how to get out of it it
was like
um one particular video I think the one
she's talking about the other day or it
was a couple weeks ago I think I posted
how you should bring extra locks and
hotel rooms because I put a piece of
duct tape with a rubber band I put the
rubber band over the latch close the
door and then opened up the door so
there's and they have a very scary
initial it is very scary but my my point
and it's and I was saying it's about
perspective because when I saw and I and
I wrote in my video this is not my
original video I saw this and I decided
to try it for myself I didn't have the
Creator's name I even wrote that if
anyone knows them tag them
when I saw the video I didn't think oh
well that person showing the bad person
how to get in someone's house now I
thought oh I better carry more locks
with me so when I posted it I actually
thought wow this is why I would carry
you know two other I have these travel
locks that I use or whatever that I take
me and I was kind of telling you know
women specifically whoever
you know the dangers and to carry more
stuff but everyone was on me oh now
you're showing the bad guy how to get in
and now you're showing this and that
people it's just it's you're gonna have
that and in some cases you know that
attention is still attention and
whatever but it's never my intention to
show a bad guy you know you you can you
can Google anything pretty much and
learn how to break into a car steal a
car create a bomb you know like they're
all there's all kinds of things you
don't need tick tock to show you
otherwise so
um anyways my whole thing is to say like
go you know try everything post
everything and see what works and and
you know I know I did give up at the
beginning but I gave up on the thing
that wasn't working and then I brought
the solution to it by bringing something
that did work and so really it's about
momentum and keeping it going and just
never giving up
Peter how do you deal with negative
comments people saying I mean even
though your stuff is uplifting and fun
and family friendly there's still people
who hate their own lives and leave nasty
comments how do you deal with that I saw
a video recently and it was talking
about the 80 20 Rule and it said no
matter what you do in life 20 of the
people are not gonna like what you do
so if you get a hate hate comment just
say oh that's one of the 20 and don't
neglect the other 80 that do like what
you do you have to put the haters aside
focus on the people that are there for
you because I mean with a falling over
of over a million people
why are you going to focus on just a
handful of negative negative people it
just doesn't make any sense
I really wish I had that perspective at
22. I started my Channel at 19 and if I
got a nasty comment it like destroyed me
and really set back the growth of my
channel because I was afraid to go off
and make more content
um cool well let's dive into like tick
tock's growth like how important are
are you guys hijacked on Trends are you
how important are keywords or like
hashtags how important is using the
music where do you guys stand on that
Peterson I guess for me I really because
I do something so different I do
um puppet comedy videos I'm not using
the sounds I'm not using hashtags I
don't participate in any Trends I don't
do any Duets I just kind of do my own
thing and I think that's one of the
things that's really helped me because I
feel like a lot of people see a specific
dance and they say oh I'll do that you
know it worked for Charlie demilio but
they're not doing anything to make it
unique and there's how many other people
doing the exact same thing so I think
the uniqueness is what people are
missing out on they think they can just
have success by doing anything and
that's not the case you have to really I
would say take something and put your
own spin on it to make it your own
instead of just copying everybody else
so you wouldn't take your puppet and do
a demilio dance
probably not
I like it respect it Michelle how about
you
um actually I totally agree with Peter
uh if there is a trend like maybe not a
dance because you really don't want to
see me dance I Don't Dance well but if
there is a specific Trend whatever it
might be what I will do with that Trend
if I do decide to participate in it if I
can figure out how to do all the edits
is edit it and create it with my own
Niche so I can't really think of one
right now but if it's a particular song
even anyways I always let's say it's a
transitional thing well I'll transition
into my tactical clothes or I'll do it
you know but I always keep it around my
Niche whatever that might be and in
terms of songs I always have a song in
the background
um
but again it's super low like I put it
at three percent just to have it kind of
you know
um Associated to my video but it's
really I just kind of grabbed the top
releases or sorry the new releases or
the viral ones and again just in case
one does kind of go viral if they do hit
the song I might be you know kind of up
up in that top 10 spot or whatever just
more for visual but I never do Trends in
terms of dancing
and I just keep things to my Niche no
matter what
what um analytics are you guys paying
attention to like what numbers are you
looking at maybe not obsessing over
although sometimes you know we look at
our numbers and obsess over it but like
Beyond just the followers growth what
what numbers mean the most to you on a
regular basis
I think for me it's probably watch time
I mean you want people to sit there and
watch through your entire video if
they're clicking off after the first
five seconds obviously you're not doing
something right so you have to hook them
at the very beginning and keep them
there and if they'll watch it all the
way through twice maybe that's even
better
do you would you pull a video down if it
had poor watch time in the first hour
and then post it again it's tempting but
I I try not to do that because I have
had videos that kind of flopped at the
beginning they end up taking off later
so I really very rarely do I ever delete
or private video I just kind of let it
go wherever it's going to go
okay so you're like video by video
looking at watch time and just seeing
how you can get better
yeah sometimes
how about you Michelle
uh I've checked watch time and that's so
interesting because you are so right
it's great to know that you're capturing
your audience in those first kind of you
know whatever three five seconds
um I think what I would I focus on is
just really views
um whether you know but I don't think it
I intentionally or you know I don't
intentionally think oh I'm gonna go
check my analytics
um
I I just kind of watched the views and
see oh my God this one flopped and I
know like every time I say I post a you
know a fitness or a travel or a family
one or whatever they just don't do as
well so I just I kind of go by that just
quickly that okay I should do more of
this content also too like you know how
many comments are coming in if you're
only getting a few comments on the video
you're like ah people aren't commenting
so there must be a reason why and and
then I I basically judge or base my next
videos on the information that I've got
and I mean and of course if brands are
reaching out to me um not that I'm a
huge um how can I say like you could put
a spin on pretty or like a safety spin
on pretty much anything
um so they have me sometimes look at nla
analytics and engagement and things like
that but it's not something I do on a
regular basis I just have fun and I put
it out and I really enjoy it
I love it what about length of videos
are you are you experimenting are you
playing with it does it matter
um I guess for mine I try to hover
around the 21 to 30 second Mark for the
most part and one of the big reasons I
started doing that is because I believe
when Instagram real started they had a
30 second time limit so I I wanted to
make tick tocks and Instagram reels the
same and post them to both platforms so
I believe now reels lets you do 60
seconds but I still that's just kind of
what works for me is around that like 25
second range
got it so super short how about you
Michelle
friends or little fun things or replies
or whatever like that's kind of a
trending I try to keep it like kind of
that
thicken because there's not much
information in a trend if I'm doing like
safety tips I usually try to keep them
three to four safety tips usually it
takes me around that 45 second Mark if
it's a lengthy one where I'm describing
something or a situation or an event
that happened to me this and that it may
be a little longer but I would say I
like to stay around the 45 second and
try and keep it as uh like engaging as
possible you know and get that what's it
called at the beginning you know that
like the catch you know make something
and then I also title it also I try to
keep my titles as you know eye-catching
uh as I can again I'm doing this
literally by myself on my phone in Tick
Tock for the most part I'm just using
like simple editing tools I don't get
too fancy and are you guys putting the
exact same thing to Instagram reels and
YouTube shorts are you playing with it
pretty much I do have some variations
sometimes
um I have an issue with a video on Tick
Tock or something so it'll get taken
down and it'll stay on another platform
so there is a little bit of a difference
but for the most part I make a video One
Day One video a day and post it to all
my different platforms I do have to get
better with that as especially YouTube
been
kind of like
I've tried YouTube a little bit and
again like again mostly Fitness stuff
and I would post like workouts or you
know product reviews or this kind of
thing but I keep forgetting about the
shorts and I don't know why because my
boys all watch YouTube shorts and
they're always on YouTube and it's just
something I never and you're right if
I'm posting a tick tock I hop over to
Reels most of the time why don't I just
head over to YouTube and it's literally
laziness like just forget or sometimes I
I'm not sure and I don't have that extra
like five minutes to say because I never
know like I gotta get a little bit more
used to it and I literally think once it
becomes a habit then I'll be fine with
it
and how are you guys turning this then
into business right so like Peter is it
brand deals is it is it selling the
merch Michelle is a promoting your gym
like how do you actually then monetize
because there's no ad model so how are
you monetizing the growth that you're
getting on Tick Tock I would say for me
um I I don't make a ton off any one area
but it's just little areas that add up
um the brand deals the going live
getting tips The Tick Tock Creator fun
the YouTube fund I mean all that like I
said just kind of adds up little by
little pretty much the same thing I've
had I I'm I was very fortunate that
um especially like well I mean even
recently like I'll go through a dry
spell and then all of a sudden like I've
had great kind of Partnerships with some
pity some pretty big Brands and
sometimes like it's you know at the time
or I I don't have an agent it was just
you know people reach out to me and I'm
a bit skeptical at first but the good
old cop in me does all the research and
the investigation like are these guys
real and
um how skeptical were you of Ida when
she reached out I was so I was I totally
linked I Linked In You and I checked you
I checked you everywhere you know like I
just I want to know and I and and to be
honest I don't do many of these
interviews because I don't know I just I
don't know you know what's your bottom
line what do you want are you a scammer
you know
[Music]
um so uh but obviously you're legit and
uh and that's how I work with all my
stuff so kind of like Peter I I get a
little bit of everything and I just you
know thankfully it's not my full-time
gig I mean I don't have the gym anymore
but our Tactical Store is kind of like
you know where I come every day but I
almost want to say that you know content
creation is literally almost like as you
would probably know a full-time gig also
it just increa like my mind is always
going it never shuts off because you
know there's every opportunity for a
video is every opportunity for you know
like a Content creation or anything like
that so it's like sometimes I wish my
brain would shut off but hey that's just
the way I'm
I've always been like that so it doesn't
really change too much
how excited are you guys about YouTube
shorts monetization
and do you see Tick Tock move in that
direction
I hope so I would love to make more
money on the content that I'm already
making
um I'm really excited to see what
YouTube shorts will pay I have no idea
what that's going to look like yet but
here in I think they said beginning of
February we should be finding out so
that'll be exciting how about you
Michelle well you're not posting enough
there yet and and in Canada I want to
say what bill just passed or is passing
and I mean Canadians don't get paid
anyway so it's for me it's something
that I really never had so I only I only
get literally my money from Brands I
don't get my money from like the Creator
fun and or in Canada anyways I'm sorry
Peter where are you from America oh
yeah it is Canadian too so we got the
Canadians here on the panel okay yeah so
you guys know I think it's bc11 I wanna
I I don't have the info but it's going
to change a lot of the broadcasting kind
of um like industry in terms of
monetization and all that thing so
I you know as I said thankfully I don't
get my you know my only money from this
and it's just because I did it because I
love to do it that being said I'm not
gonna say no to kind of money
and I'm gonna try to do that but I I and
I think YouTube is going to be a little
bit better in that so I should get on
that train
yeah to qualify for monetization on
YouTube shorts you need to have 10
million views on your videos which
sounds like a lot but shorts is not that
hard to do and you guys would easily go
on and crush it with the stuff you're
doing on Tick Tock they um I forget what
the breakdown was I think it's 40
percent
to creators but first the the music
companies get their cut so like Music
Company kits are cut they didn't say how
much that is but so many of the shorts
have music which creates just a
nightmare for copyright because you
can't put long-form music in most videos
like you put a Taylor Swift song in your
long-form YouTube video it's going to
get demonetized right away so they had
to make a deal because so many so many
of the shorts and tick tocks Instagram
meals have the music so the the record
labels get their their cut first and
then it splits I think 60 40 to you 60
to YouTube but it's like it's money you
know right like nobody else is paying
you that the the funds are so little and
as they keep adding more people in it's
like you're people are making peanuts
off of it
um it's interesting to see where it goes
right like YouTube owns the monetization
game and we'll tick tock
catch up to it there's a lot of people
who are in YouTube making
six not yet off shorts but off of
Regular content like you can have a
seven figure business even eight figure
business just off of ads
on anything else you sell is is bonus
whether you're selling your merch or
brand deals or anything else
so be curious to see how many people
like if you start getting paid
well maybe Peter because you're posting
them both and you used to be you used to
be YouTube hardcore and then move to
tick tock if you if you started getting
paid thousands of dollars every month to
do it like how much does YouTube then
become the first platform instead of
tick tock
um I think it's I think it's where the
probably where the money is first and
then where the views and and followers
and stuff are you want to cater to where
you've got the biggest opportunity
it's not like it's not like you're gonna
stop on any platform but right which
which gets the priority
yeah and have you seen have you seen
anything on on shorts from your
experience there that's that's helping
you hurt new strategies advice
um I like I said I just post the same
thing to shorts as I do on Tick Tock um
I heard somebody once say that they
don't even bother with a description you
know YouTube makes you jump through a
lot of hurdles whenever you're posting
video is it made for kids do you want to
add in screens all this stuff so I had
somebody say they just kind of blew up
by just posting a video you put a title
on it and let leave the rest to kind of
the chance so that's what I started
doing I'm just literally upload the same
videos I take from a tick tock to
YouTube shorts title it and I'm done I
don't do a description or anything else
with it and that's worked pretty well
for me
um so you never know you just got to try
different things
how much do you guys pay attention to
the cover image for tick tock because
I'm I'm more in the YouTube world and
like thumbnails are everything you don't
have a good thumbnail the video is dead
uh but with YouTube shorts most views
don't happen from a thumbnail that
happens from just people scrolling so
whether you put a thumbnail on it or not
it's like five percent of views come
from somebody clicking on the thumbnail
on Tick Tock how important is it having
a good cover image and how much time you
guys spend on those
I think for mine I don't really think
that the thumbnail is going to
necessarily get you more views I mean
like if people are scrolling through
your for you page obviously they're not
seeing the thumbnail of the video I
think really what that's doing is that's
making your page look more presentable
so that they can go back and find it
whenever they're looking later
um so I don't do anything too fancy I
try to put a caption on it with the
little editor whenever you're choosing
your thumbnail just so you could find
like different topics easier and then
also in addition to the thumbnails I
also take advantage of the playlist so I
have like 10 or 15 different playlists
that have you know all of the same type
video on my page so those are easily
findable later but I think it's more of
a presentation Thing versus actually
getting more views from that I would you
know like exactly what what Peter just
said
um I do create one every time sometimes
I'll forget but for the most part I do
and I do it all the same way but it's
more of like you said for Aesthetics I
always have the same type of header I
use like the blue outline one and I you
know I have just specific things I do
all the time
um I also you know add captions of
course and any I don't go crazy with
like adding stickers and this and that
but again I'm just editing from you know
a simple editing from Tick Tock and I
don't want to distract too many people
but I do think that sometimes if they
are using you know fancy editing it is
nice and pleasing to the eye and it kind
of keeps you watching I just personally
I don't have the time for it but I do
you know every video I add one and I
make sure it's like you know
um depending on the video it's it's it's
eye-catching and especially if you're in
Wi-Fi and you're kind of seeing that
cover photo in Tick Tock going back and
forth back and forth It's kind of neat
to get you know and depending on the
video a pretty cool
um you know you know space in the video
where it you know it's eye pleasing but
other than that that's that's all that I
do
I didn't know that was a Wi-Fi setting I
just learned something there too it's
like why is it sometimes I see them
moving and sometimes not so it's if
you're on Wi-Fi versus data well I think
so because every time it's if I'm on
data it it doesn't it doesn't do so that
was just literally my my conclusion oh
got it okay
Peter how impactful are the playlists
can you track views from playlists or is
it just again it's presentable and you
don't think it has a big impact from
people actually finding it you know I'm
not really sure the answer to that I
just do it to keep things together like
one of the series that she mentioned
earlier is that do boy band um videos
where we surprise people with a boy band
so if that's something that somebody
really likes they shouldn't have to
scroll through my like 700 plus videos
to find those just click on the boy band
playlist and they've actually built it
now I think this is a fairly recent
feature where if you're within a
playlist it'll automatically Scroll once
the video ends it'll go to the next one
so that's a nice feature for people to
be able to just see whatever kind of
content that they like from me the most
I love that I don't think I built any
playlists out so I have I have some
to-do's after this to go and update my
Tick Tock do you have playlists Michelle
no that'll be on my to-do list too I
don't even have one in fact I think I I
use the pin feature where I you know pin
three at the top and uh and even at that
I was talking about those like I I
pinned like my most views like my most
viewed videos and then I think I I was
watching uh someone actually saying it
was a great tip that those shouldn't
really be the ones out of the most
viewed they should be you know kind of
about you about your content or
something or something you're proud of
so I kind of changed my three up or I
left like you know my most viewed but
then I also put one like Ida was saying
the one that really helped somebody
because that's a super important you
know hand gesture to know and you know a
saved two lives that I know of in any
ways that was actually you know on TV on
Inside Edition that kind of thing and
then almost one just kind of about me
you know so
um those now are pinned but in terms of
playlists that's on my to-do list that's
the difference between 1.1 and 1.7
playlists but that's the growth that's
how you get there
Peter how do you think about the pinned
how do you approach those three
um I am not currently using pinned
videos
um I just have so many different things
I do and another thing I don't like
about that is it takes it out of
wherever it would have been and puts it
at the top so I just upload every day
and let the new ones be at the top and
don't worry about pinned too much how
important is the time of day when you
post that is a very good question I
don't really I haven't done the research
to know the answer to that I usually
Post in the early evening like 6 p.m 7
P.M in my time I'm in Central Time Zone
and it might have a way I would
recommend maybe not posting in the
middle of the night when nobody's awake
but I think that it probably doesn't
matter that much I don't really know
because I find there's some videos I
personally I have posted around 6 p.m
those ones take off but the ones that I
post like earlier in the day is like no
it's like I think depending on when your
audience is online that would also play
into if it blows up no yeah I think that
does have something to do with it
whenever people are the most active and
I figure people are going to be on after
school or work in the evening so that's
kind of why I lean more toward that time
frame how about you Michelle do you care
about time posting or you just put it up
I I care a little bit but sometimes like
but I never know the right time that's
the problem like I've had you know great
videos take off at seven o'clock at
night on Eastern time
um you know and then I've
I I usually and this is like so Random
it's not something I read or anything I
don't like to post before 12 noon like
but you know before noon and I don't
know why because noon I mean people are
up at nine if you're in you know the
other time zone or if you're in mine
you're up you know at noon it's lunch
time I just have this thing I don't want
to in case it just bombs so usually I'll
go 12 and same thing obvious I won't
post in the middle of the night I
usually in my latest I think I've ever
posted was like 9 00 p.m and even at
that it's just because I haven't had
time throughout the day or whatever to
get something out there but that that
would be like my window but for no
particular reason
how long does a tick tock live this is
one of the biggest things in the YouTube
Community we're still trying to figure
with shorts because the biggest benefit
of YouTube is your videos live forever
so that if you're making whether it's an
entertainment video like Peter or
education like you Michelle somebody in
five years could still find it funny or
still find it valuable and so long form
YouTube works because videos from five
years old are still getting recommended
and referred when shorts came out like I
don't is it more like
it dies like Instagram like a week after
you post a Niger real it's dead nobody
cares anymore is shorts like that or not
and we're still trying to figure it out
what's your sense on Tick Tock is you
know if you have a video does it can it
a year later still get you views six
months later like a month later well how
long is the life lifetime of a video
I don't know I don't know what the time
frame is exactly but I do think that
there is a possibility that something
can do well later let's say for example
that somebody posts your Tick Tock from
a year ago to some kind of subreddit and
people a bunch of people start clicking
on it and then Tick Tock all of a sudden
says oh well this is obviously notable
let's push this out I don't think that
it's out of the realm of possibility
that something from a year ago could all
of a sudden start getting some traction
so I would say essentially Anything is
Possible
yeah I have to agree with that I I can
never it and it's funny you say that I
have a video currently that I posted
last
no I wouldn't say last in February so
it's almost been I mean well we're in
November
um and it's it's non-stop taken off but
it had stopped for a while and it's it's
at almost my most viewed video so my
most viewed video was at 24 million this
one's creeping up it's now at 21.3 but
it was like where are you why are you
watching this this is this from so long
ago and it to me it's not my most
exciting video I am talking education
and I'm talking about Tick Tock
challenges and how to be careful and to
think about it and you know don't act if
you know it's very like mom-like so I
was kind of surprised that it's doing as
well as as it is
that long ago you know so I don't know
the answer to that question because you
know it's like the algorithm who really
knows how it works I don't know have you
guys seen videos take off and then die
and then take off again without
like a Reddit post or without like some
foreign link happening
well the crazy thing about that is you
really never know where the views are
coming from I don't know if somebody's
posted my video to read it or not
um but I mean I think I have experienced
that somewhere something will be doing
really well and then it kind of plateaus
and then it takes back off and I can
typically tell if there's a bunch of
people commenting on it and then I'm
saying why is why is there so many
comments coming in on this video so I
just I don't there's no real Rhyme or
Reason on what's going to do well or
when it's going to take off or die it
just you just have to guess and hope for
the best I guess
sometimes you work so hard on a video or
I do work so hard and it just bombs and
in other words you just do this simple
thing that you would never think and all
of a sudden takes off and I'm like oh my
gosh I work so hard on the other one you
get it's not frustrated you're happy the
other video is doing well but you're
just surprised I know it's funny
do you guys ever repost a winner like if
it took off and then kind of stopped a
month later or three months later would
you repost the same thing
one of the things I typically do is I
will do like my top maybe say 10 videos
of the entire year I'll repost at the
end of the year so like the last 10 days
of the year are my top videos of that
year so kind of like a recap of what was
successful and then sometimes those re
um repost go viral again so it's worth a
shot I'm taking notes
and it also it also gives me a break for
not having to do content for two weeks
because I'm just they're already ready
would you do that throughout the year
like hey take take your best post from
January and then post it again in June
sometimes whenever I'm not ready to post
because I post a video every day and
sometimes it's like an hour before I'm
ready to post and I don't have anything
ready I'll just pull one of those older
videos and throw it up there I try not
to do that too much because I know
people want to see the new content I
mean if they can scroll back and find
the old stuff why do they want to see it
again you know at the top of the feed so
try not to do it too often but there are
instances where
uh video is successful I'll try it again
same thing see if it goes viral again or
just like I said if I don't have
something ready to go I'll just repost
an old video
do you know how many people who are
watching the video or people who are
actually following you versus like brand
new people into the ecosystem
I don't know the exact numbers but
because of the for you page there's
probably a good percentage of people
that just see it that don't follow
yeah and there's probably a good
percentage of people who follow you who
then don't even see it
a lot of inactive accounts I mean I've
had my Tick Tock for almost three years
now so what are the odds that the people
that were early followers are even still
using the app they might not even have
Tick Tock downloaded anymore you just
don't know I'm yeah so just I'm
wondering then if
you had a you had a banger in January
and then you posted in June again how
many people would even know that you
posted that like most of the views
probably at least 80 20 are brand new
people who haven't seen your stuff
before
it's a good thought yeah and I was gonna
say you know who'd be gutsy enough to
say oh you're reposting this then again
it is Tick Tock and they're very
they'll tell you uh I just find the
crowd on Tick Tock I like and that was
one of the big things an adjustment for
me because on Instagram it's also nice
and fluffy and they're your friends and
you know them somehow and then I got on
Tick Tock and I was like whoa you guys
are either you're like really good
keyboard like I always say the keyboard
Warriors or you're just downright rude
like I've gotten some just nasty ones
and I'm thinking and like kind of like
you said Evan it's like it hurts
sometimes but
you you adjust and you realize it's just
a different platform I've been called
worse or you know you just kind of and I
really don't let it bother me anymore
but at first and sometimes it still does
um but you know some of them are just so
not even relevant to the video like oh
you're ugly or oh shut up or you're a
Karen or like so Random you know
um but but yeah like I think that
happens when people don't know you right
so especially when you grow quickly and
with tech talk you're being introduced
to so many new people who've never seen
you before yeah
people feel a lot more at Liberty to
just say the first thing that pops into
their mind which if it's not a positive
thing they'll just say it anyway yeah
and the good thing is your your
followers who have been following you
for a while will actually stick up for
you so then they start arguing in your
comments and you're like hey guys thanks
for the engagement I don't even have to
say anything anymore but I used to sit
there and defend myself at the beginning
like well you know and then I'm thinking
why am I doing this I'm getting so hurt
and so angry and then you know um it was
a fellow Creator just said you know what
this is what it's all about and you know
what as long as you're happy with your
content and you believe in it you know
there that's what they do and I'm like
oh okay and now like my perspective of
that is just completely different
got it Peter you talked about going live
is that a important part of your
strategy or is that just like Community
get to know your followers a bit better
like you see if you go live it ends up
boosting your channel and your your
other videos or it's just a community
thing
um it's interesting you had mentioned
that whenever I first started going live
and reaching the point where you can go
live I really feel like I noticed a big
jump in I just gained 300 followers from
going live something like that
um and it seems like as it's gone on
it's become less successful and I used
to go live like almost every day and now
it's just kind of like a once a month
thing if I think about it
um because I don't feel like there's as
big of a reason for me to go live if
you're not getting a lot of tips and
you're not getting a lot of viewers I
mean it's still beneficial for Community
Building kind of thing but it's not
really to me anymore as effective as it
was when I first started doing it
got it so maybe you know my last
question before I give Ida a chance to
ask her last question uh what if that's
not working for you like what do you
find is the thing that's working the
best for you right now as we're
recording this
for both of you
I'll let you go ahead because I don't
know what I'm gonna say yet
uh well you know it's kind of almost
Part B to the live part is I used to go
live a lot more or a lot more not not as
much as you I to me I thought once a
week was great because I again my
content was a little different I was
just more about introducing but after a
while I found that
I don't know I just it it wasn't
happening for me for whatever reason and
it wasn't I wasn't getting what I
thought I was going to get out of it and
so I actually stopped doing them all
together which probably isn't the best
thing I should do them once in a while
but instead what I decided to do with my
time and it's and again it's because I
mean I have four boys a business and
this and that so like taking the time
out to do a live to get nothing or not
what I thought out of it now I take that
time and engage back with my followers
to create a community you know uh in a
different way so I make sure I try to
respond to as many you know comments and
engage with them that way or you know or
reply videos so that way I'm still
engaging with the people who are
actually connecting with me and um if if
you know the one thing I focus on I I
always say this is authenticity like I
just be me and sometimes you know I
often say especially coming from the
Fitness industry you know Instagram
versus real life and you know I used to
always but like oh the photo shows the
photo has to be perfect before I post it
and it was always so focused on that now
with Tick Tock hey this is me and you
know sometimes I look good sometimes I
don't and I'm still going to put a video
out there because I'm keeping you safe
you know so uh in that respect I just
make sure I'm authentic
I love it
all right Peter
I got time to think what do you got I
think what I'm doing right now
um I don't exactly remember what the
question was but
um I think one of the things that I'm
doing right now that I I Look to do is
I'll post different types of videos all
of them fall under the comedy umbrella
but like one of the things that I do is
celebrity look-alikes and that's a
series that I know usually does pretty
good so I will rinse and repeat if a
celebrity lookalikes video does well
then I know I need to post more of those
and I'm I do some series that are up to
part like 40 now because it's just done
so well I keep doing more of those so
that's one of the things I focus on
because if you do something totally
different every time it's really hard to
gauge
how it's going to go or anything like
that but certain things that do well
historically will probably do well again
there you go now you can make your
Michelle looks like iJustine look-alike
video yes
all right Aida what's your last question
what do you got for us how much do you
value like video responses versus text
responses which one do you prioritize
for me because of what I do I I
basically keep it strictly comedy based
so a lot of people will address things
in video form I really don't do that if
I feel the need I'll typically just
write back to him and that's it and for
me pretty much the same thing because if
I get a comment and all the hellos you
know I'll just say hello I won't unless
it's an actual question and it's content
or an idea that I haven't done before I
will just usually answer back in text if
not I have this uh you know the method I
use I actually I'll click reply with
video I'll kind of tape the air for
three seconds just to kind of hold it in
my drafts and then I'll go back to it
later to create an actual video so it's
kind of like oh my content like my my
content or to-do list is there or I'll
just jot it down on a piece of paper oh
my God she gave me a good idea and
here's what video it's from and I'll go
back to it but for the most part it's
just easier to do the text that way and
I'll answer with video only on content
that I can know that's going to create a
good engaging video and one last thing
Evan Peter do you have your puppets
can you do us something with the puppet
I have to hide my mouth I'm not a
ventriloquist here I'll say hey what's
going on everybody it's blue Elmo
oh
I love it right there too on my shirt I
love it
that's great well Peter and Michelle
thank you thank you for your energy and
your wisdom and the time today for
people who are watching this who want to
learn more about you will will link up
in the description below where where do
you want them to go
I think for me it's uh my main platform
is Tick Tock Peter prankster also the
YouTube Facebook Instagram mostly just
Tick Tock and YouTube are my main
platforms is Peter prankster for both of
those and for me same thing I keep it
nice and simple my first name and my
last name Michelle with an N Michelle
loss on all the platforms and of course
I have my website michellelost.com
amazing we'll link that up in the
description below thank you guys for
watching and appreciate uh you guys
giving me some education as well today
thank you guys thank you to see my
one-on-one with Tick Tock Legend Gary
vaynerchuk check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe I'll see you there
I'm talking about something that the
world thinks is a contradiction I don't
understand why anybody should ever
verbally dress down an employee